what kinds of things I mean just tell us
about the art what what do you like
drawing what do you I like drawing
whatever comes into my head I start at
the bottom of the page and work my way
up and often don't know what it's going
to be I like to start with feet
and then go up to the knees I don't know
if it's going to be a man or a woman yet
first I'm gonna up the thighs I have to
make my mind up quick and then it
becomes whatever it's going to be and in
terms of all the other stuff you've done
I mean how does registers are sits do
you enjoy it more than you enjoyed
stand-up or I don't put them against one
another they're all good they're all the
old have their own high sports and but
the art was very good because you can do
it at home you don't need to go anywhere
I catch planes and taxi isn't all that
it's just you go up air then shuffle
over to your desk and this I'm finished
with stand-up it was lovely
and it was lovely being good at it there
was the first thing I was ever good at
and I'm delighted and grateful to it and
this is nice because people think I'm
good at this and it's lovely to wallow
in it
so we won't see you back on stage will
we know what no it's my big the
Parkinson that's made my brain work
differently and you need a good blend
for a comedy you need to everything you
see should have favor six alternatives
behind it
decision you'd see something and attack
it from behind and let that story make
itself up and it said it's a madly
exciting thing to do this story is
taking place and you don't know where
it's going and it's a delay it's a
privilege to be part of it
how are you I mean you seem very well I
am good drugs
I take six pills a day and I have to be
careful when I take them and this is
dangerous in London because I only
arrived the day before yesterday so a
jet like so it wasn't really the time
when I got what was 8 o'clock on my
watch but it wasn't either o'clock
really because of jet lag so I was a bit
sugary yesterday I'm okay today despite
the fact that you've been very public
about having Parkinson's you don't seem
to be slowing down I don't think it's a
good idea to slow down I have ideas and
gross opinions on it I'm always been
asked to go to Parkinson's things and
spend time with Parkinson's people
having lunch or something like that and
I don't approve of it that sounds
terribly from pshh I don't approve but I
don't think you should let Parkinson's
define you and all your pals be
Parkinson's people I've gone and seen
people who are more advanced than you
you see what Jesus am I going to be like
that I don't think it's particularly
good for you so I don't do it
I just do my life and if my hands too
shaky I don't draw you know I'll draw
later when it stops shaking now it comes
with the pills as well if you have to
take them at the wrong time you can just
shoot my left hand shakes but it's good
today have you been surprised how much
you can achieve and how your life can
kind of continue despite that I'm
surprised and delighted but the ideas I
had were right then you can do anything
you'll please and I hope little
schoolboys and school leavers are
watching me doing these things and see
if you can do what you like you can
write please you can write songs you can
be funny on stage you can play
banjo you do drawings it's none of it
was nobody came along with a magic wand
and said get allowed to do that now you
just have to do it and stretch yourself
and because you get good at one thing
people will listen to you more people
should listen to comedians and fewer
people should listen to politicians
should listen to comedians and poets
they're telling the truth so any
politicians in particular that you think
that we should be ignoring at the moment
Boris anybody who listens to Boris needs
professional help because because he's a
big silly tough and it's Britain's been
listening to big silly talks for years
this time they listen to themselves and
go on with it because I create the
British they're a great nation and it's
and they belong together
they like each other we speak to
Parkinson's that the charity Parkinson's
and they said that and you give people
inspiration in terms of what you have
achieved and how open you are because
one of the things about Parkinson's is
that people have got lots of
misconceptions and they said that you
know you really help other people who
have it yes I think people get upset I
get upset because you certain things go
wrong where your brain goes adrift and
affects your body and so you walk
differently you won't like a drunk man
sometimes and you're frightened you'll
be judged on it and and you shake
sometimes and you know sometimes you
can't get your money into your wallet
you change and the waiter has to take it
from you and put it in and I was having
the plane yesterday day before and I
went to go to the bathroom and I
couldn't get my seat so I had to get the
steward bears to help me you have to go
over that and see excuse me I'm having
trouble good knowing my secret to help
me and they always say certainly
and help you and it's it takes a bit of
getting used to you used to be in this
guy who's in charge of himself and and
suddenly you're not and it's good for
you to reach out to the people around
you for help
that's a fairly good thing and people
like doing it and we've recently heard
that Ozzy Osbourne has been diagnosed
see I thought he had two ages ago I saw
him drawing and he said love to see his
drawings because almost that seething
she did from his house he was always
drawing and I spoke to him about it and
I said no it's rubbish but it isn't
rubbish and I wanted to see more of
David Bowie's drawings and Ozzy is one
of the world's great people have you
spoken to them I haven't spoke to him
about the Parkinson's but that's another
thing I don't do there's come in as mr.
Parkinson's they know all about
Parkinson's I don't know all I hardly
know anything you were talking earlier
about and your wife tweeting things in
social media because we all saw the
pictures of you when he'd been through
the carwash with your shopping I know
put it in the back of the truck and she
was I didn't know she was going to the
carwash she thought it was in the
backseat and I go got washed it washed
my salad and suddenly the world knows
but you're not on social media why
because I do like the people who are on
social media they want if they were me I
was on Twitter but I made such a bunch
of horrible people that I used to put in
questions like how much is that doggy in
the window and who wrote the book of
love and the phone did shallow and
boring and they were not slow to tell me
then a couple of them were challenged me
to fight and I thought what am i doing
mixing with these matters
so I come off it I don't need any more
friends and social media you can keep it
that they seem to be an unhappy bunch of
people